ya limpiamos esas calles estaban
cubiertas con piedras bien hace parte de
un batallón de empleados municipales que
se moviliza cada vez que kramators es
alcanzada por los misiles y la
artillería rusa el frente de batalla se
acerca cada vez más y más desde bajo
mundo nos da mucho miedo todo lo que
pasa nos da mucho miedo
Desde que la lucha por la vecina Back se
intensificó durante el invierno las
ciudades atacadas al menos tres veces a
la semana en esta ocasión Los rusos
lanzaron una decena de misiles durante
la madrugada dos de ellos cayeron en el
patio de este colegio en el centro de la
ciudad considerada el eje administrativo
y militar de la provincia de donest en
control de Ucrania ataques como Estos no
son
cada vez son más frecuentes Y es que nos
dicen los habitantes que tienen miedo
que en la medida que el frente de
batalla se acerque y la contraofensiva
ucraniana se intensifica o empiece de
una vez estos ataques se van a hacer
mayores
obligatorio si el frente de batalla se
acerca más vamos a comenzar la
evacuación obligatoria de la gente pero
espero que nuestros militares sostengan
el frente de batalla donde se encuentra
actualmente
miles de habitantes huyeron de la ciudad
después de que comenzó la invasión a
gran escala pero con el paso del tiempo
han regresado al menos 25.000 personas
viven aquí a pesar del peligro un
ejemplo es este cohete que cayó en medio
de la noche frente a una vivienda en un
barrio Residencial esta vez Tuvieron
suerte y no explotó no lo sentimos lo
encontramos tirado siempre oímos
silbidos en la noche pasan por encima
de vuelta al colegio
asimilación y de un grupo de profesores
y alumnos que intentan limpiar los
escombros confiesa que siente mucho
miedo cada vez que hay un ataque teme
que alguien pueda morir
esperamos Que la contraofensiva empiece
que nuestros hombres los expulsen y sus
cohetes no puedan alcanzar clamatorios
expectativa por lo que pueda pasar en
las próximas semanas es grande muchos
creen que Su futuro dependerá del rumbo
que tome la guerra una vez que haya
empezado la contraofensiva